I've put a hold on my weekly uploads for
a while now to take the time to grow as
a filmmaker and learn from people around
the world making a difference in their
respective fields
I was concerned with my last humps of
happiness as I came across as a false
version of myself but it's seen it's a
super positive guy that doesn't see the
negatives in anything with gracious
characteristics and one that never bends
the room when actually it's quite the
opposite the forms are made by the way
in which I wish to see the world the way
in which I can hopefully learn to see
the world around me it's so easy
nowadays to get sucked into depression
and anxieties through the bad news we
are given all the time I want to show
you an example myself and my good mate
Bren winds into an informal settlement
and care done to make a form view from
two different perspectives objectively
looking at the negatives and another
finding the beauties within this is my
journey to find happiness and I want to
share it with you I'm Dan mace and I'm
not happy well as happy as it may seem
but I'm definitely getting it and I
encourage you to join my journey here's
what the world looks like when you
choose to look at it the wrong way
and this is how beautiful it actually is
I was commissioned to make three phones
for great big story and also me Channel
I'm super excited about this they have
chosen to only tell positive stories
about the world something I truly
believe it
this is the first forum by a friend of
mine affair phenom Jonah otherwise known
as the spinach king
what's epic about the story is the lack
of resources people from this community
have and what they do with so little to
make a huge difference
people generally look at the townships
and so that we can leave they filled
with hate and risks but I'd like to
share it is no way like that
yes there are criminals just like in
every society and I guess the times of
can be dangerous but I've never been
surrounded by more giving and welcoming
community
I can't wait to share this phone with
you yes a little behind the scenes to
get you excited
head over to great big stories channel
to check the full phone